[Music]
wrench how are you this morning Steve
Harvey right now is doing jumping jacks
he's off the hook the party's off the
hook yes oh yes the party's off the hook
can I just say one thing it was the
biggest love obviously ever and on the
biggest stage but this is what I'm happy
about could you imagine if Warren Beatty
would have said and the best picture
goes to moonlight and then the flood
happened and they would have gave it to
Lalo and what if it would have been
flipped and moonlight originally had won
but then they gave it to lala land
could you imagine taraj if he hints and
what a story it would have been on I
mean it's still hurtful don't get me
don't get me wrong but what if it had
been flip-flopped
what if moonlight originally had won and
lala land was the real winner
could you imagine seriously could you
imagine especially after last year's
Oscar so white you know that
african-americans are the
african-americans are not getting any
love at the Oscars and then that would
have happened
holy Moses that would have been well it
was already an awkward moment that would
have been a really really awkward moment
oh my goodness yes but here's the thing
though Emma Stone says she still had her
card of winning Best Actress correct
yeah she's gone on the record to say
that so then what is Warren Beatty
talking about when he opens it up and
says I see Emma Stone and la-la-land
there are two powers not adding up no
there's two cards for every award and he
just picked up the second card of death
somebody somebody on that side of the
stage probably had the leftover card for
Emma Stone and gave him the wrong card
and nobody checked it and I think that
that's what happened
what's what's the movie that changed
your life did you ever have one of those
where it really affected you how
affected me in what kind of way well
negative I I came out of Jaws and didn't
go swimming in the ocean for you oh
that's a good one
fatal attraction attraction fact you
never wanted to go take your girl to see
right yeah because she was always
looking at you at the corner of your
eyes like ah okay so this what's going
on when I'm gone so I would probably say
fatal attraction for most men it's the
one movie that probably changed our
behavior I just made sure I didn't own a
rabbit that's that's that's the first
step just don't don't buy a rabbit there
all right
let me dive into some hoops here Lonzo
ball at UCLA and his dad has come out
and he's made a few comments that he
thinks Lanza is gonna be better than
Steph Curry and you know there's nothing
wrong with your father showing support
and love but it feels like he's adding
more pressure on Lonzo ball oh oh
there's a bull's-eye okay
first of all there was already a huge
bullseye on all the ball kids you know
the Melo goes for wood 92 yeah and you
know pops is out here saying his kids
now I don't not sure this is confirm
that Lanza will only play for the Lakers
and then you come out and say he's
better than Steph Curry number one first
of all win pac-12 Player of the Year
first before you start attacking the
two-time MVP is he the best player in
the packed pac-12 oh there's the kid up
in Washington that's pretty good -
that's a freshman mark he'll fold once
in Oregon and you get Brooks in Oregon
you get a look he's certainly in
consideration for being the best player
look TJ Lee it's got to get some votes
as well we got the big kid in Arizona
look I'm just gonna say this
I love the support
and that's what a dad is supposed to do
but when you start comparing him to
known you know quality you know like
Steph Curry who is a two-time MVP and
has done so much in the league already
people are already going to hate because
of you know he's so successful at UCLA
but now you're adding more pressure to
it so maybe his son is up to the
challenge but if your pops you've just
got to be careful because there's gonna
be guys as soon as you take that next
step at that next level and be like okay
so you think your stuff you think you
the next Jason Kidd alright you won't
think Russell Westbrook you don't think
Chris Paul
you don't think Kyrie Irving you don't
think these guys are like you know kind
of biting at the chops to get after this
young man but do you think he what
you've seen how good is Lonzo ball it's
hard to tell in the college game he's a
great college player now and certainly
for a freshman and to have that type of
success at a young age but it's so hard
because every time you watch a college
game there may be one NBA Challenge
player on the floor at one time it's
when you go to the next level you're
going to get 12 all-american you're
going to get 12 player of the years so
it's different it's hard for me to gauge
college players because of the talent
level that's on the floor at that
particular time he's good I think he's
obviously going to be a top five pick
will he be the number one pick certainly
he has that capability of doing that but
it's hard to gauge there's a look at our
last draft who's been that successful
[Music]
hasn't even played this year and will
not play this year and I like what I saw
from Ben Simmons at LSU more than I did
Lonzo ball not to say the Lonzo ball is
not going to be successful
I thought Simmons you know was able to
go inside I thought he was able he's not
as good a shooter as ball but I saw more
of a diversification with with Simmons
he could go inside bigger but you know
until he gets on the floor of the Sixers
you know we're not quite sure how to
assess him on the probe again mr. ball
there is nothing wrong with
boosting your son and putting him on a
pedestal I get that and that's what
fathers are supposed to do but you got
to be careful with some of your comments
when you compare him to a Steph courier
guys that's accomplished who has won 2
MVPs at the highest level and have the
championship under his belt and been to
the finals two times in a row and your
son is still I mean there's so many more
chapters to be written on this young
man's career you just have to be careful
I know he has confidence and all his son
oh boy but just be careful just be
careful what you say reg will be calling
the Thunder at the Blazers coming up
Thursday night at 10:30 Eastern on TNT
all right a couple of things here Shaq
and JaVale McGee help me understand this
reg that Shaq has made it personal in it
and it really feels like Shaq was
bullying JaVale McGee what's your take
from this to a certain degree but here's
the thing
Shaq didn't the fool has been on TNT
since shotgun has gotten to our network
and he it runs every week and it makes
fun of everyone just not JaVale it just
so happens JaVale has a lot of
highlights Shaq took it personal when
JaVale called him stop Kooning you know
for your bosses that that's a low blow
from from JaVale but I think JaVale was
fed up and look from my knowledge from
most 7-footers they are all sensitive on
the planet as strong and as big as he is
he has a very sensitive side if he feels
like he's being attacked he is gonna go
on the offense same way that's how he
played basketball and he took it
personal and he kind of crossed the line
a little bit but so did you ville I like
the comments by his mom coming out and
coming to his defense I'm not quite sure
you want your mom coming out and coming
to your defense as a pro player but
because I have love for Pam McGee and
I've known her for so many years and she
played with Sheryl at USC I can
understand where she's coming from she's
sticking up for her son
I'm glad that mama O'Neal got involved
yeah
and told Shaq cut it out enough is
enough and hopefully this is now water
under the bridge but I think both sides
acted immature to 7-footers who are very
sensitive
JaVale McGee who is now a key player on
a championship potential team and his
plane up to his potential finally and I
think Shaq just needs to let it go
danlove batard had some comments about
Magic Johnson where he was questioning
you know hiring Magic Johnson
he has questioned other people getting
jobs a John Lynch with the San Francisco
49ers as their GM or Phil Jackson with
the New York Knicks but it seemed to
take a different turn there where you
know Keyshawn Johnson on his radio show
talked about you know is this racial
shouldn't we question well I know it's
Magic Johnson and you know the sacred
cow here but anybody any star who gets
whether it's Kevin McHale or Larry Bird
or Magic Johnson or Michael Jordan you
know shouldn't we if you got the job in
the front office with the Pacers now
shouldn't we question whether are you
the right person to run the front office
for the Pacers 100% absolutely and I
think this is another part of why Magic
signed up he understands he's not going
to be Teflon because now everything will
be on you before it was on Jim buss and
Mitch Kupchak well now that you've come
in and cleaned house now the clock
starts to tick you know absolutely Magic
Johnson's on the clock and he should be
criticized for his moves going forward I
don't think there was a racial component
to it because you know Larry Bird is
taking his hit in Indiana Kevin McHale
we saw what happened in Minnesota in
Houston so for all great players that
sign up for that to be in front of the
fiery lines when you take on the that
type of position of President Michael
Jordan took the hit in Washington and
Charles Barkley was critical of him so
you signed up for that and you know
that's that's a part of it I think it's
fair game it's easy for us to sit on the
side
and you know throw darts but you know
magic wanted to get back in the game and
his first order of business and you know
what let's just say this Mitch Kupchak
did a lot of great things for the Lakers
but it was time for a change
he usually responsible for two
championships so let's give him credit
but if you look at the success of the
Lakers over the last five years it has
not been there
it was stale management and Jeanie buss
understood that and she brought in the
face of Laker nation the most beloved
player arguably in the history of the
franchise in Magic Johnson so he cleaned
house but - it's on the clock now
so let's judge him going forward as
opposed to saying she's a bad hire you
can't say he's about hire until we see
some of the results I'll leave you with
this I made a bet with Barkley I said
that I'll take the pelicans as the
number eight seed against Golden State
in the opening round and Charles laughed
and I said would you give me a car if I
won that bat and he said he would give
me a Kia and he would take the dennis
out for a steak dinner wait hold on what
do you mean like the pelicans would beat
yeah yeah well I love you I had to get
some long odds here and I figured that
you know my Pels with you know boogie
and Anthony Davis and that's a different
matchup for Golden State and you know
maybe maybe they could shock the world
I'm I will favor Senor not to the big
men in the game but they need someone to
get them the ball first of all and if
Holliday is gonna Holliday have to stay
healthy which he has shown that he has
not and he has to play big in big
moments in the playoffs which he has
shown that he hasn't so can I get in on
that very unlike you usually are pretty
good and at your bed yeah yeah not a
good one I know I know well I only have
to take him out for a steak dinner
whereas your
Nakia yeah yeah so I get a steak I get a
steak dinner for the dance and a Kia and
Charles just gets a steak dinner well I
will say this that will arguably be the
biggest 1/8 upset probably in the
history of the game that probably
Trump's what was that Dallas or uh going
to be Dallas well Denver didn't Denver
with Dakar Denver beating Seattle yes
but that was the best of five this would
be a best of seven yeah we're really
creamed absolutely you're you're saying
that New Orleans would win four games
that's what you're saying four games or
games like golden and I get a Kia okay I
mean I that kind of insight will be on
display Thursday night at 10:30
tournament empty Thunder in the Blazers
safe travels reg thanks bud the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]